the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we start the part of our course
that in the old days in the traditional
treatment began the engineering form of
calculus in other words what we have
done is we have defined the derivative
the instantaneous as being a limit of an
average rate of change we spent a great
deal of time proving certain theorems
about limits now what we're going to do
is to analytically take the limit
definition of a derivative which we have
already done qualitatively apply our
limit theorems to this and develop
certain formulas for computing
derivatives much more quickly from a
computational point of view than having
to resort to the original definition in
other words what we're going to do is to
go from a qualitative approach to the
derivative to a more quantitative
approach and for this reason I just call
this lecture the derivatives of some
simple functions to create sort of a
mood over here now the idea is this
let's go back to our basic definition
the derivative of f of X when X is equal
to x1 f prime of x1 is by definition the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 f of x1
plus Delta X minus f of x1 over Delta X
in other words the average rate of
change of f of X with respect to X as we
move from x1 to some new position x1
plus Delta X taking the limit as Delta X
approaches 0 now just to illustrate this
let's take for example f of x equals x
cubed in this case if we now compute f
of x1 plus Delta X minus f of x1 recall
that F is the function that does what
given any input the output is the cube
of the input so f of x1 plus Delta X
will be the cube of x1 plus Delta X
minus f of x1 that's minus x1 cubed we
now use the binomial theorem in other
words notice again how mathematics works
you introduce a new definition but then
all of the old prerequisite mathematics
comes back to be used as a tool over
here we use the binomial theorem the x1
cubed term here cancels with the x1 cube
to
I'm here and what we left this is what 3
X 1 squared times Delta X + 3 X 1 Delta
x squared plus Delta X cubed and to
emphasize the next step that we're going
to make let's factor out a delta X now
going back to our basic definition we
must take this expression and divide it
by Delta X the key idea is that in the
last step we're going to take the limit
as Delta X approaches 0 the limit as
Delta X approaches 0 means in particular
that Delta X is not allowed to equal 0
and as long as Delta X is not 0 the
Delta X and the denominator cancels the
Delta X in the numerator to leave 3 X 1
squared plus 3 X 1 Delta X plus Delta x
squared and now finally to find what f
prime of x1 is we simply take this limit
as Delta X approaches 0 and notice what
you're doing over here when you let
Delta X approach 0 we're going to be
using the limit theorems namely the
limit of a sum is a sum of the limits
the limit of a product is the product of
the limits we can then take each of
these limits term by term notice that
the first term not depending on Delta X
its limit is just 3 X 1 squared each of
the remaining terms have a factor of
Delta X in them as Delta X goes to 0
then each of the remaining terms go to 0
and we wind up with by our basic
definition that f prime of x1 is 3 X 1
squared in particular since x1 could
have been any real number here what we
have shown is what that if f of X is
equal to X cubed then F prime of X is 3x
squared and the important point here is
simply to observe that we got this
result by applying the basic definition
to a specifically given function to
generalize this result let f of X be X
to the N where n is any part of the
whole number and I want to emphasize
that because you're going to see as this
proof goes on that I really use the fact
that n is a positive whole number now
emphasize to you where I do this I'm
going to mimic the same thing I did in
the special case in our first example
when we simply chose em to equal three
namely I compute F of x1 plus Delta X
minus F of x1 since the output is the
nth power of the input that's just x1
plus Delta X to the N minus x1 to the N
now as long as n is a positive whole
number we can expand it by the binomial
theorem the first term will be X sub 1
to the N that will cancel this X sub 1
to the N the next term will be n X sub 1
to the n minus 1 power times Delta X and
now I do something that's a little bit
cheating I guess what I do next is is I
observe that every remaining term in the
binomial theorem expansion here has a
factor of at least Delta x squared in it
so rather than compute all these terms
individually recognizing that I'm going
to let Delta X eventually approach 0 i
factor out a delta x squared and say
look at the remaining terms have the
form Delta x squared times some finite
number I don't know what it is but it's
some finite number I'll put that well
let's just take a look and see what that
means in particular now if I take this
expression and divide through by Delta X
we're assuming again that Delta X is not
0 because we're going to take the limit
as Delta X approaches 0 and remember our
big harangue about that when we approach
the limit we are never allowed to equal
it Delta X never equals 0 consequently I
can cancel a Delta X from the
denominator with a delta X maneuver ATAR
canceling a delta X from the numerator
knocks a Delta X all together out of
this term and leaves me with just a
single factor of Delta X in this term
what I now do is reverting are referring
to my basic definition I now take the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 as Delta X
approaches 0 this term not depending on
Delta X remains NX to the N minus 1 and
here's the key step the limit of a
product is the product of the limits
this approach is zero this is some
number and 0 times some number is 0 and
therefore all that's left here is n X 1
to the N minus 1 against if this was any
X what we have is what if f of X is X to
the N where n is a positive whole number
and where I use that fact I use that
fact to use the binomial theorem then
the derivative is NX to the n minus 1 in
other words if you want to memorize a
shortcut now that we know the answer
observe the seams to differentiate X to
the N all you do is bring the exponent
down and replace it by one less but for
heaven's sakes don't look at that as
being a proof rather we gave the proof
then observe what the shortcut recipe
was don't say isn't it easier just to
bring the exponent down and replace it
by one less instead of going through
this whole long harangue over here no
this is how we prove that result
notice what we have now shown is that
the differentiate X to the N for any
positive integer n the derivative is
just NX to the n minus 1 so far we do
not know if that result is true for any
other numbers we'll talk about that a
little bit more later well so much for
that example let's look at another one
let's suppose that we have two functions
f and G which are differentiable say at
some number X 1 that means among other
things that F prime of X 1 and G prime
of X 1 exist now define a new function H
to be the sum of the given two functions
by the way we have to be very very
careful here in general F and G could
have different domains notice that X has
to belong to both the domain of F and
the domain of G for this to make sense
consequently I write
down over here that X belongs to the
domain of f intersect domain G in other
words it belongs to both sets the domain
of F and the domain of G because if X
didn't belong to at least one of these
two this expression wouldn't even make
sense in other words X must be a
permissible input to both the F and G
machines now what my claim is is that in
this particular case H prime exists in
other words H is also differentiable and
it's obtained just by adding the sum of
these two derivatives in other words
this is the result that's commonly known
as the derivative of a sum is the sum of
the derivatives which of course sounds
like it should be right but I'll comment
on that in a moment also what I want to
show is simply this that H prime of X 1
is simply F prime of X 1 plus G prime of
X 1 ok and my main purpose is to
highlight the basic definition that's
what I want to give you the drill on
namely how do we compute H prime of X 1
we must look at H of X 1 plus Delta X
minus H of X 1 over Delta X then take
the limit as Delta X approaches 0 that's
the basic definition that will be used
over and over and over at any rate
sparing you the all of the details here
let's simply observe what that H of x1
plus Delta X since H is the sum of F and
G is f of x1 plus Delta X plus G of x1
plus Delta X consequently H of x1 plus
Delta X minus H of x1 is f of x1 plus
Delta X plus G of x1 plus Delta X that's
this part minus f of x1 plus G of x1 now
the idea is I want to divide this by
Delta X I also have some knowledge of
the differentiability of F and G
separately so I would like to combine or
regroup these terms to highlight that
fact for me so what I do is I group
these two terms together these two terms
together and then divide through by
Delta X in other words H of X 1 plus
Delta X minus H of X over Delta X is
what f of x1 plus Delta X minus f of X 1
over Delta X
plus G of X 1 plus Delta X minus G of X
1 over Delta X now for my last step I
simply must take the limit as Delta X
goes to 0 well just look at this
bracketed expression the limit of a sum
is the sum of the limits so to take the
limit of this expression I take the
limit of these two terms separately and
add them by definition the limit of the
bracketed expression as Delta X goes to
0 by definition is f prime of X 1 and as
Delta X goes to 0 this term here becomes
G prime of X 1 and by the way for the
last time let me give you this word of
caution again do not make the mistake of
saying G when Delta X goes to 0 my
numerator is 0 therefore the fraction
must be 0 no when Delta X goes to 0 sure
if you replace Delta X by 0 the
numerator is 0 but so is the denominator
in other words this is our old story
that the derivative becomes a study of 0
over 0 if you let Delta X equal 0 in
other words the whole point is what that
as Delta X approaches 0 this by
definition is f prime of X 1 this by
definition is G prime of X 1 and
therefore we have proven as a theorem
that F prime of X 1 H prime of X 1 is f
prime of X 1 plus G prime of X 1 that
the derivative of the sum is the sum of
the derivatives now the main trouble so
far is that every result that I've
proven rigorously for you you have
probably guessed in advance that was
going to happen
you say who needs this rigorous stuff
when we could have got the same result
by intuition and this is where the riff
between the way the pure mathematician
often teaches calculus and the way say
the applied Man teaches calculus often
comes in the point is is that the places
that you can get into trouble often
aren't stress soon enough so before we
go any further let me show you that you
must be careful that up until now we
have been very fortunate when we say
things like the limit of a product is
the product of the limits fortunately in
the sense that they worked out the way
the wording seem to indicate let me give
you an example of what I mean by say
beware of self-evident I claim for
example that the derivative of a product
is not the product of the derivatives
necessarily and the best way to prove
that to you is not to say take my word
for it this is one of the beauties of
computational mathematics you can always
show by means of an example what's going
on for example let f of X be X plus 1
let G of X be X minus 1 now the
derivative of x plus 1 is simply 1 the
derivative of X minus 1 is also 1 namely
we differentiate this as a sum the
derivative x is 1
Dhruva constant is 0 in other words f
prime of X is 1 G prime of X is 1 on the
other hand if we first multiply F and G
X plus 1 times X minus 1 is x squared
minus 1 and the derivative of that is
what well to differentiate x squared we
just saw bring the exponent down replace
it by one less that's 2 X derivative of
minus 1 is 0 in other words if you
multiply first and then take the
derivative you get 2x on the other hand
if you differentiate first and then take
the product you get 1 now it is not true
that 2x is a synonym for 1 for all
values of X in other words if you
differentiate first and then take the
product you get a different answer than
if you multiply first and then
differentiate in other words
self-evident or not the thing happens to
be false in fact let's see how the
theory helps us in this case see what
I've shown you here is that this result
isn't true or I should say that this
result is true that the equality isn't
true what I haven't shown you is what is
true and again to emphasize our basic
definition let's do that now let's show
how we can use our basic definition to
find the correct result what we do is is
we let H of X equal f of X times G of X
and we're going to use the same
structure as before we are going to
compute H of x1 plus Delta X subtract H
of x1 divided by Delta X and take the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 we do that
every time all that changes is the
property of the particular function that
we're dealing
in any event if I do this H of x1 plus
Delta X is obtained by replacing X in
here by x1 plus Delta X and H of x1 is
obtained by replacing X by x1 over here
so I wind up with F of x1 plus Delta X
times G of x1 plus Delta X minus F of x1
times G of x1 and now the problem is I
would like somehow to be able to get
terms involving F of x1 plus Delta X
minus F of x1 G of x1 plus Delta X minus
G of x1 and I use the same trick here
that I use when I prove that the limit
of a product is the product of the
limits namely I am going to add in and
subtract the same term that and this
will help me factor in other words what
I'm going to do here is this I'll write
down this term now I say to myself I
would like an F of x1 term to go with
the F of x1 plus Delta X so what I do is
I write minus f of x1 then I observed
that G of x1 plus Delta X is a factor
here so I put that in over here see G of
x1 plus Delta X see notice I can now
factor out a G of x1 plus Delta X from
these two terms and have the form that I
want left over but of course this term
doesn't belong here I just add that
myself our society practice it so now I
put it in with the opposite sign namely
plus F of x1 G of x1 plus Delta X and
now put this term back in here minus f
of x1 times G of x1 in other words all
I've done is rewritten this but by
adding in and subtracting the same term
which does what dividing through by
Delta X I factor out the G of x1 plus
Delta X from these two terms that leaves
me with F of x1 plus Delta X minus F of
x1 over Delta X because I'm dividing
through by Delta X now what i do is i
factor out f of x1 from here and divide
what's left through by delta x that
gives me F of x1 times the quantity G of
x1 plus Delta X minus G of x1 over Delta
X I get this thing over here now my
final step is what I take the limit as
Delta X approaches 0 well let's do the
easy part first
as Delta X approaches 0 this becomes F
prime of x1 and as Delta X approaches 0
this becomes G prime of x1 this of
course remains F of x1 and I guess you
would argue intuitively that as Delta X
approaches 0 x1 plus Delta X approaches
x1 therefore G of x1 plus Delta X
approaches G of x1 that would give you
this result over here I have put a
little asterisk over here because I want
to make a footnote about this you know
even though you would have allowed me to
say that this approaches G of x1 as
Delta X approaches 0 it is not in
general true that we can be this sloppy
about this I want to mention that later
but meanwhile I don't want to obscure
the result that I'm driving at namely
assuming that this is a proper step what
we have shown now is that the
differentiate a product you
differentiate the first factor and
multiply that by the second then add on
to that the first fact that times the
derivative of the second now that may
not be self-evident but what we have
shown is that self-evident or not this
result follows inescapably from our
basic definitions and our previous
theorems and by the way to finish off
the example that we started where f of X
was X plus 1 and G of X was X minus 1
notice that if we use this recipe f
prime of x1 is 1 G of x1 is x1 minus 1 F
of x1 is x1 plus 1 G prime of x1 is 1
and if we now combine all these terms we
get twice x1 and that's exactly what the
derivative of the products should have
been in other words just to summarize
this thing off notice that when we were
back over here this was the result that
we were supposed to get in other words
to differentiate the product our basic
formula tells us that it's the first
times the derivative the second plus the
second times the derivative of the first
and let me just go back to this
parenthetical footnote that I wanted to
mention for you it is not always that
the limit of G of T as T approaches a
is G of a remember our whole study of
limits said you cannot replace T by a or
a by T automatically in fact what type
of examples did we see that this guy's
into trouble for example let G of T be T
squared minus one over t minus one okay
then the limit of G of T is T approaches
one well as long as T is not one t minus
one is not zero we can cancel a team -
one from numerator and denominator that
leaves us with t plus one as t
approaches one T plus one approaches two
in other words the limit of G of T as T
approaches one is two but G of one
doesn't even exist G of one is zero over
zero in other words it's not true here
that as T approaches one G of T
approaches T G of one those you can say
that when x one approaches X 2 f of X
one approaches f of X two it doesn't
have to be true why then could I use it
in my particular example and by the way
the situation in which the limit of G of
T as T approaches a is G of a comes
under the heading of a subject called
continuity and that is a later lecture
in this particular block we'll talk
about it in more detail then but for the
time being let me show you why we could
use this in our present case again we
use a trick we want to show that as x1
plus Delta X gets close to x1 G of x1
plus Delta X gets close to G of x1 and
to do that that's the same as showing
that this difference gets close to zero
as Delta X gets close to zero what we do
is utilize the fact and this is very
important we utilize the fact that G is
differentiable and what we do is and it
doesn't look like a very significant
step but it is what we do is is we take
this expression and both multiply it and
divide it by Delta X I don't know if you
can see the method to my madness here
the whole thing I'm setting up here is
that when I do this the bracketed
expression now looks like the thing that
yields G prime of x1 when you take the
limit and now that's exactly what I'm
going to do I'm going to take the limit
of this
depression as Delta X approaches 0 the
limit of a product is the product of the
limits as this bracketed expression as
Delta X is allowed to approach 0 this
bracketed expression by definition
becomes G prime of X 1 and obviously
this is just the limit of Delta X as
Delta X approaches 0 which is 0 the fact
that G is differentiable means that this
is a finite number and any finite number
times 0 is 0 in other words the fact
that G was differentiable tells us that
this limit is 0 and that's the same as
saying that the limit of G the limit G
of x1 plus Delta X as Delta X approaches
0 is in fact G of x1 as self-evident as
it seems this is not a true result if
the function G is not differentiable or
it may not be a true result if G is not
differentiable well so much for that
there is one more recipe that's very
important called the quotient rule with
the one we just did what's called the
product rule see how do you
differentiate the product of two
functions there is an analogous type of
recipe for differentiating the quotient
of two functions and since the proof is
very much the same as what I've already
done I leave the details to you there in
the textbook will you can go through
that in more detail if you wish but the
result is this if F and G are
differentiable functions the quotient is
also differentiable and the way you get
the result and again notice how
non-intuitive this is get this in terms
of logic if you're trying to memorize it
logically you take the denominator times
the derivative of the numerator and you
subtract off the numerator times the
derivative of the denominator and then
you divide the whole thing by the square
of the denominator see again notice how
overwhelming this cost becomes if you
try to memorize every result rather do
what memorize the basic definition and
derive these results and believe me once
you use these results long enough you
will memorize them automatically just by
repeated use well any rate let me give
you an example of using this remember
before we could only differentiate X to
the N if the exponent was positive
suppose f of X is
to the minus n where n is now a positive
integer that means minus n is negative
how would we differentiate this and the
idea is we say look at if this has been
a positive n we could handle this but X
to the minus n by definition is 1 over X
to the N we know how to differentiate X
to the N when n is a positive number
what do I have now I have a quotient so
I use the quotient rule F prime of X is
what it's my denominator which is X to
the N times the derivative of my
numerator my numerator is a constant so
it's derivative is 0 minus the numerator
that's minus 1 times the derivative of
the denominator but for a positive
integer n we know that the root of x to
the N is n X to the n minus 1 all over
the square of the denominator but the
square of X to the N is X to the 2n and
if I now simplify this I have what this
is 0 this is minus n this is X to the n
minus 1 this comes upstairs as a minus
2n so I have minus X and X to the n
minus 1 minus 2n that's the same as what
minus n X to the minus n minus 1 and by
the way this is a rather interesting
result
now that we've proven it suppose we said
to a person let's just bring down the
exponent and replace it by one less well
if we brought down the exponent that's
minus N and if we replace minus n by 1
less that would be minus n minus 1 and
lo and behold that's precisely the
result that we got in other words by
using the quotient rule for example we
can now show that the rule that says
bring down the exponent and replace it
by one less applies for all integers not
just the positive integers in later
lectures we will show that it applies to
fractional exponents as well as to any
real number exponents as we go along but
I just want you to see the structure
here and in fact I think in terms of
what this lesson is all about we have
given enough examples I think we might
just as well summarized here and let it
be and let the rest come from the
reading material and the
learning exercises in general and the
summary is simply this the basic
definition of a derivative is f prime of
x1 is the limit as Delta X approaches 0
f of x1 plus Delta X minus f of x1 over
Delta X that basic definition never
changes we always mean this when we
write this but what is important is that
this basic definition can be manipulated
to yield and now I use quotation marks
convenient because I don't know how
convenient something has to be before
it's really convenient but convenient
what recipes meaning what
convenient ways to find the derivative
you see what's going to happen in the
remainder of our course as we shall soon
see in the next lecture in fact what
we're going to start doing is using
derivatives the same as they always were
intended to be used but now we are going
to have much sharper computational
techniques for finding these derivatives
more rapidly than having to resort to
the basic limit definition well enough
about that for now until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate